The action film "The Misfits” follows a
group of vigilantes who convince prison escape
artist Richard Pace, played by Pierce Brosnan,
to help them pull off a gold heist in the
fictional country of Jazeristan.
The gold is originally meant to finance terrorist
activities, and a man named Schultz is storing
the fortune for a terrorist organization in
one of his many high-security prisons.
With a team of misfit criminals, including
con artist Ringo, skilled fighter Violet,
and the mysterious Prince, Pace and company
hatch a plan to steal their bounty from a
Jazeristan penitentiary.
Their basic intention is to give the entire
prison population severe food poisoning, dress
up as medical personnel, then sneak out with
the gold.
A simple plan?
Not exactly.
Let's dive into the multiple twists at the
end of "The Misfits."
"Steal their gold, stop the terrorists.
Let's go to prison, shall we?"
The personal antagonism between Schultz and
Richard Pace is obvious from the beginning
of the movie due to the heavy implication
that Pace previously slept with Schultz's
wife.
Schultz therefore has a vendetta against Pace,
and Pace reciprocates the rivalry by humiliating
Schultz whenever possible.
This motivation explains the reasoning behind
the numerous outlandish diversions and red
herrings during the robbery.
First, by giving the entire prison population
food poisoning, the team causes hundreds of
inmates to suffer intense vomiting and intestinal
distress.
This throws the institution into chaos, and
allows the robbers to take advantage of the
distracted staff during the pandemonium.
However, for Pace, the health of the convicts
is simply a means to an end.
When Wick expresses concern about their well-being,
Pace heartlessly brushes off the matter.
Pace's main objective was to embarrass Schultz
in his own facility, regardless of the collateral
damage to hundreds of people who have nothing
to do with his personal vendetta.
Secondly, it's eventually revealed that the
gold bars weren't transported as bricks, but
instead melted down into the shape of a statue.
While Schultz's team chases after a van they
presume is carrying the riches, the real gold
is wheeled out of the facility under the pretense
of repairing the sculpture.
This means Schultz is further disgraced when
he catches up to the van, only to find it
empty.
Once Schultz does catch the van, Pace's crew
is outmanned and outgunned — that is, until
a fleet of soldiers with a military aircraft
inexplicably emerge from the sand dunes, despite
there being no cover for miles around.
These men are supposedly under the command
of the Prince.
The regiment surrounds Schultz, claiming to
be from the fictional sovereign nation of
Salwhan.
Whether this is another trick, or a reveal
that the Prince really is royalty remains
somewhat ambiguous, but the tactic does allow
them to leave unharmed.
What isn't ambiguous, however, is that the
vigilante thieves condemn Schultz to death
by divulging his whereabouts to Abu Hirawa,
the head of the terrorist organization they
just robbed.
As to why Hirawa would punish his lackey in
charge of protecting the gold instead of going
after those directly responsible for swindling
his wealth standing right in front of him,
that remains an unanswered question.
Even if Hirawa believed that the Prince was
royalty from a sovereign nation, he has no
reason to care about the status of the thieves
who stole his treasure.
For that matter, if the group really was trying
to make the world a better place and stop
terrorism, why didn't they kill Hirawa right
then?
They had a literal squadron of soldiers surrounding
the area; they could have brought down the
head of an international terrorist organization
and destabilized his entire establishment.
They already displayed that they're not above
killing people, as Violet has killed a number
of guards during the course of the film, so
why not one more death for the cause?
"I don't date men.
I kill them."
For the final bait-and-switch of "The Misfits,"
Schultz's goons are holding Hope hostage,
and just as she's about to be executed, it's
revealed that Violet was the one being held
captive, which spells bad news for those guys
as she slays her abductors with ease.
How these kidnappers mistook a blonde white
woman for a brunette Korean American is another
unsolved mystery.
Were they not given a general description?
Or a photo from her Instagram?
Similarly, in the penultimate scene of the
movie, it appears that Richard Pace has gone
back on his word and stolen the gold for himself,
but he returns to the team remorseful, the
gilded statue in tow.
When watching "The Misfits," the audience
is in the same shoes as Schultz.
Due to the many false trails the script sets
up, it's easy to become just as confused about
what's going on as the people being robbed.
Though one or two plot twists can be exciting,
too many curveballs tend to result in whiplash.
But that's the narrative's entire intention:
to keep us on our toes, throwing us from point
to point, and keep us constantly guessing.
If that's the goal of "The Misfits,” then
mission accomplished.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.